one of Facebook's creators is calling on
the government to break up the social
media giant Chris Hughes helped Mark
Zuckerberg found Facebook in their
Harvard dorm room in 2004 Hughes left
Facebook in 2007 the New York Times
opinion piece Hughes writes he's angry
that in his view Zuckerberg focus on
growth led him to sacrifice security and
civility for cliques he calls Zuckerberg
power unprecedented and an American the
company has more than 6 billion monthly
active users across all of its platforms
and that includes Facebook whatsapp
messenger and Instagram Facebook
released a statement that says in part
quote accountability of tech companies
can only be achieved through the
painstaking introduction of new rules
for the Internet Chris Hughes is with us
good morning thanks for having me on
American that's pretty tough I think so
I think we have a long tradition in
America of holding power accountable I
mean after our Constitution is built on
checks and balances and sometimes folks
in the private sector who are CEOs of
companies just get too big so just like
we've done with Standard Oil AT&T we say
this is a monopoly a market is frozen
there is no competition and there's no
accountability and the government needs
to step in and break it up right your
point is there should be a check on this
power but why do you have to break up
Facebook Instagram whatsapp why break it
up because I think most Americans know
that the best way to hold a company
accountable is competition what keeps
happening now is there's another privacy
scandal or another election scandal
seemingly every week at least every
month and then people get outraged they
get so angry they say oh I'm leaving
Facebook I'm going to Instagram not
realizing that Instagram is owned by
Facebook yes and then they become
resigned to the fact that we can't do
anything so we can't boat with our feet
we can't vote with our eyeballs and so
you say government to step in of course
we can well I would go to my book or I
would go to my walk outside or I would
go to my friend on the telephone listen
I would love to I think most Americans
would love to say oh I don't really need
social media but that's like thing I
don't really need my iPhone I think that
or I don't really need we don't get a
sense weekly you can well exactly there
is competition you can go to Samsung
with Facebook there's really nowhere
else to go
Facebook has 85% of the revenue
in the social networking sector are you
gonna go to LinkedIn but I guess thing
is you're saving Americans from
themselves is essentially what you're
saying I don't think that's quite right
I think Americans want a competitive
network where they have options
otherwise there's gonna be scandal after
scandal and that we need competition you
know Adam Smith was the first to say
markets are productive they're
innovative when there are players that
are vying for it and this is what it was
like in the early days of Facebook you
know after we started it there was
MySpace or Friendster livejournal tumblr
we can go through a long list and that
made us better it meant that we had to
develop features keep the site secure
think about where else users can go and
that competition doesn't use my point of
saying that mark is a good kind person
well and then you go on to slam the
company but yet you don't believe that
there's something nefarious going on at
Facebook or do you know I don't I say in
the piece that and I feel that mark is a
good kind person we've been friends for
15 16 years at this point he has too
much power listen I don't know I really
don't know if we're gonna be friends I
think there are some my vote well
they're probably not obably not but
there are some friendships where you
have disagreements and still stay
friends have you reached out to him you
mentioned that you talked to him in 2017
because I'm curious when did you realize
there was a problem and did you go to
him and say houston we have a real
problem you need to do something here
yeah well I first became uncomfortable
with what was happening on Facebook in
the summer of 2016 in the African
election and I did not in that summer
write a note
I didn't after that election it became
increasingly clear that there was a
problem and then the Cambridge
analytical scandal happens and in that
intervening period I did spend some time
with with Mark and talked about some of
my concerns but because we've been
friends first and I've haven't been at
the company in over a decade we talked
about our families more than anything
else after Cambridge analytic I did
start to speak up and we've had some
exchanges since then about what's
happened at the company so this is a
gradual process for me too it's not like
today I'm you know the critic in
yesterday yesterday I was a cheerleader
I like a lot of people I think marveled
at Facebook's growth and I've only
become critical in the past 2 to 2 to 3
years other Facebook employees are at
former Facebook employees are also
speaking up - you're not a lone voice
out there
yeah there there are a good number of
particularly of folks in the early day
because I think we all feel some sense
of responsibility because because we
were part of the early days of Facebook
I mean I I will be the first to say I
helped create newsfeed my name is on the
patent and news feed I think in many
instances has led to major problems I
mean I think it helped me because
there's the rise of nationalist leader
or as fake news the argument is that
there was an original sin which is that
that grabbing attention and and
prioritizing attention over all these
other values was embedded in its
original design that this isn't this is
just the late flowering of something
that was there in the beginning
I think listen Betty you I think you're
right to say that these all these apps
were built to attract more and more
attention and I don't know if I would
say that's an original sin but it's
definitely a trade off which is I think
been pushed too far now because now
Americans are paying for these services
with their data and with their attention
an hour a day on average for Facebook 53
minutes for Instagram and and again I
don't think that would be necessarily a
problem if there was an alternative
where you would go and pay and not have
your data collected or paid and not have
advertisements but we have no
competition your point is there's no
market accountability it is it is a
monopoly and that's why you're saying
that the government has to come in do
you think lawmakers actually have the
tech savvy or understanding in order to
do this I think some do and there's a
growing movement of them last year in
marks testimony I think unfortunately a
lot of people came away with the
narrative that their garden added
together the government but there are
quite a number of folks who are anything
but clueless in the government and it's
not just its Elizabeth Warren yes but
it's also people like Ted Cruz David
Cicilline is a congressman in the house
there is leadership coming out of the
woodwork and I will say not just on
Facebook but on monopolies in general
three-quarters of American industries
have become more concentrated and I
think there's there's accountability
coming and just real quickly you could
say that your wording that mark has
surrounded himself with people that
reinforce his beliefs instead of
challenging them
what role does Cheryl Sandburg play in
that you know having been the company in
10 years so I I don't have a any view
into their private conversations but I
do think that there's a sense of we have
to self protect over there which is
changing a little bit but I
thing needs to change quite a bit more
maybe the two of you all should sit down
and talk he clearly knows your
capabilities and abilities would you be
open to that of course Mark's been a
friend I care about him and I think he
has too much feel is available to
moderate interesting points you are
thank you very much Chris your eminence